you're listening to the dollop on the
all things podcasts all things comedy
podcasts Network sure we are brought to
you by all by the Lowell herb company
Lowell farms is a small california-based
cannabis company that has some of the
best selling cannabis products in the
state with their Lowell smokes a
pre-roll pack with seven hand rolled
half gram 5 g smokes 0.5 G half a gram
right Louis devoted to high-quality
clean and organic cannabis they have
triple lab tested from the start both
way before I recently became law nollet
as well have its own farm but also
partners and employees dozens of farms
up and down the California coast
responsibly responsibility in education
is an important part of the Lowell brand
recreational but responsible and
informed consumption I know the owner I
know the the man behind Lowell and I
have known him for a long time and he's
a really good guy and and a lot of a lot
of cannabis it's out there we know we've
talked about it the stuff that's going
on with it it's not great so this is a
company and it's keeping all that [__]
that people are spraying on we yeah
equalization has been amazing but it
also opens you up to a lot more problems
that's how you got a source where your
weed so this is a very very good weed
company the law herb pledge is to only
grow their flowers with organic
fertilizer never use synthetic
pesticides they pay their farmers a
living wage which as you know at the
dollop we find very very very good and
they only use natural materials from
seed to sale that are recycled and from
renewable resources disclaimer you must
be over 21 to purchase for recreational
use
so Lowell our company it's good yeah you
want the clean [__]
yep you want the good [__] yeah and
that's not always what's happening and
I've heard from people who smoke pot
that you can tell the difference between
how for the type of fertilizer they use
when you smoke it oh you've from people
that smoke it yeah from spot smokers
from people who have tried it have
trident but marilyn ragin people that
have given potter shocking Potter shot
yep people who inhale tried it this in
American history podcasts each week I
read a story I Dave Anthony story from
American history to my friend Garrett
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about and called it quote
is jam-packed jammed and I'm the [__]
hippo guy
they've okay names Garrity but it's good
is it four five and this is not gonna
come to tickle you
now hit him with the puppy you both
present sick arguments
oh that's some good times huh
what are your dates okay August 22nd
through the 24th I'll be at comedy on
state and Madison Wisconsin the 24th
will be taping in album two shows that
night so if you run that area please
come check it out first weekend of
September I'll be at Austin cap city
comedy that is September 5th through the
8th it looks like so just Sunday there
too and then you go garan let's calm all
shows there's just all over you see it
this is gonna be great get the ones that
come the better place to go we're gonna
be in Irvine this week on Thursday we'll
be in San Diego on Friday please come
see us in September sorry
September we will be in Sacramento and
Boise on the 13th and 14th and then in
October in Madison and Milwaukee on the
18th and 20th and then Europe we are
coming to you Stockholm Oslo
I'm sure damn Glasgow Manchester London
Birmingham Cardiff good adult
podcast.com to get tickets
one more even though I already did my
perfectly oh I know this Saturday I'll
be in Seattle I have two shows a 630 and
I think at 9 o'clock I'll be it's at
Fremont Abbey Arts Center guess I was
that kind of information again what good
what was the last part kids wants that
kind of information we have brought to
you by Brook linen they're making your
home beautiful it's the ultimate form of
self care you know that you know that
girl Brooklyn in it was founded there of
course a sheet and bedding company yeah
I found in 2014 by husband and wife team
who won
to find great beautiful home essentials
that didn't cost an arm and a leg we all
know is an issue so they want to make
you comfortable luxury linen sheets and
robes without the luxury markups they
got amazing five-star hotel sheets the
Brooklyn was the first DTC bedding
company meaning they work directly with
manufacturers and directly with
customers no middlemen none no middleman
they've got 12 beautiful linen colors
and patterns to choose from it's it's in
their name so you know it's good Brooke
linens and newest linen collection is
amazing I couldn't recommend their
products more for graduates new as
friends or family or treating yourself
to the bedroom upgrade you deserve
Brooklyn accom is giving an exclusive
offer just for our listeners get 10% off
and free shipping when you use promo
code the dollop at Brooklyn and Comm
Brooklyn is so confident in their
product that all their sheets comforters
and towels come with a lifetime warranty
the only way to get 10% off and free
shipping is to use promo code to the
dollop at Brooklyn and calm that's be
Roo kli n en comm promo code the dollop
Brooklyn these are the best sheets ever
Gareth we are also brought to you by
open fit what is open fit you ask me
without with your eyes with your eyes
yeah you did open fit takes all the
complexity of losing weight and getting
fit it's a brand new super simple
streaming service that allows you to
work out from the comfort of your living
room in as little as 10 minutes a day
and the 10 minute workouts are legit
right legit like you can really really
figured out like pitching out raising
they really a figure that working out
yeah open fit like the first few times I
was like maybe I'll just not live cuz
it's a legit like yeah that's how it is
shape I am sculpt your body and the
convenience of your own home no eyes
watching you like what happens you in a
park or whatever does that directed at
me specifically work out with amazing
trainers like Andrea Rogers founders of
founder of the worldwide sensation
extend bar yeah yeah it's affordable
it's accessible you're going on vacation
soon you're worried
Hotel won't have a gym that's it this is
the answer which happens open fit it
does happen yeah you get what you put in
you can see results within the first 30
days I have been doing it and I am
definitely losing weight
yeah you look hotter thank you hi open
Fitness change the way I workout and
texting code dollop a to 30 30 30 you
can join that gel my name's number Dave
on the fitness journey
personalized just for you right now
during the open fit 30-day challenge our
listeners get a special extended 30-day
free trial membership to open fit when
you text dollop to 30 30 30 you will get
full access to open fit all the workouts
and nutrition information totally free
again just text 30 just have dollop - 30
30 30 standard message and data rates
and then if you want to get more
information on Joe Biden just text Joe
to 303 303 o3o we also brought to you by
fabfitfun yeah I mean we know to fab
that's it's the best thing the the fab
fit bun it's a box of just joy that
comes to your house the fabfitfun fall
box is on sale now the foot so it's it's
a box of the products for ladies mm-hmm
it's got all kinds of stuff there's the
shawls there's cream there's headphones
there's makeup things that I don't
understand there's masks it's a it's a
woman's lifestyle subscription box with
full-size premium Beauty lifestyle
fitness home and wellness products that
go straight to your doorstep
each season takes the hassle out of
shopping these are full-size products
not little now is a full-size legit the
product yes so these boxes saw it fast
so sign up for years today my wife goes
absolutely bananas to lose her mind
she's like I'm just a bucket on a chair
with my pair I'm like honey
so fabfitfun is a seasonal subscription
box with a full-size Beauty Fitness and
fashion and
lifestyle products and retails for
$49.99 but always has a value of over
$200 use coupon code ballot which hurry
up because they're gonna be out of
business
use cubic on Dalek for $10 off your
first box with at WWWF a BFF on comm WWF
at fifa.com $10 off your first box used
coupon code
dalip i can't say enough about it it's
really it's great it is really great
it's legitimately really really awesome
do it do it
we're also brought to you by stamps comm
I use stamps comm yep I enjoy stamps
comm yeah I love the whole process
stamps calm is for if you don't want to
go to the post office if you just want
to do everything right out of your home
you're busy obviously the post office
hours I can do it at night if I want
when you plan office it I do keep hours
weird hours I'm usually up from 1:00
a.m. to 3 a.m. every day and the rest of
the time I sleep so you're working the
Koala schedule so you know a lot of
people that have time of the post
officer doesn't work with her schedule
that's why you have stamps calm it's one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses brings amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease like I said I use it I do orders
for the podcast and then I slap labels
on them print out a little sheet for the
for the postman to scan and then I put
it my front door and that's it and he
comes and he picks it up and off it goes
it's the person hanging ever saves time
and money right now our listeners can
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps comm and
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in dollop at
stamps comm enter dollop Ord elope
you don't want both work yeah there's a
there's a plush ultra soft fringe scarf
and this you could get in this month's
fabfitfun box yeah
I might be time for me to wear scarves
this is also an anthropology travel yoga
mat that's just it's just stuff that I'd
never be like I should get someone this
I know but then they get it like yeah
dummy
tell them you bought it for him yeah the
minor is specifically catered towards me
they say hey dumbass
here's your box yeah yeah you don't get
a note written on I get dumbass in there
oh yeah I get a handwritten note I get I
just get one it says you're wonderful
mine has made from those magazine
letters like a hostage letter or ransom
note it's not right I don't think that's
a fabfitfun box that's terrifying
does the fanfic bar box have squirrels
in it nope that aren't alive no no no
this is all just yes is different this
is very different
you're a terrifying human being well
I'll tell you I'm about to get a lot
happier know that I've know that that's
them looking for a culprit not at a
company anyway let's do the ads Aaron
let's go from the top play the song you
can watch this podcast on the all things
comedies all right we didn't do that
with the last one time 1750 nice serve
our Lord Jesus Christ Benjamin Franklin
wrote a letter to a doctor friend of his
former president Benjamin former
Franklin it's why he's on the bills yep
quote you know the cold bath has long
been in vogue here as a tonic sorry Ben
this is starting real hot Benjamin
Franklin is writing a letter to who a
friend a friend about the bath yes okay
you know the cold bath has long been in
vogue here is atomic but the shock of
the cold water has always appeared to me
as too violent and I have found it much
more agreeable to my Constitution to
bathe in another element I mean cold air
with this in view I rise almost every
morning and sit in my chamber without
any clothes whatever then half an hour
or an hour according to the season
either reading or writing Wow what a
weirdo so Benjamin Franklin just takes
an hour a day and just new dress yeah
nudes up a nudes in the morning morning
nudes with Ben that's what it's
that's what it eventually became yeah
I'm writing to you well my Jimmy John is
out I'm actually I've tied the pen to my
pecker and I'm doing it with my waste
strokes anyway I don't like baths anyway
others of the time who enjoyed
skinny-dipping or other nude activities
include John Quincy Adams Oh Walt
Whitman George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson regularly went swimming
without clothes okay I think Washington
would go in the Potomac all the time
sure right right but can't get his teeth
with them yeah no but that was an
individual thing it was considered
radical and they remained a small
minority of the population skinny
dippers mmm and Newton knew doing nude
doing of things okay until the Germans
got into Group nudism which became
popular after 1900 sure okay in 1920
Germany established its first nude beach
on the island of silt okay in German
nudism it was it was a reaction to
urbanization and rapid industrialization
okay the idea was to go back to nature
be healthy get exercise have gardens and
be a vegetarian okay are you gonna drive
around 19:30 the Berlin School of nudism
opened finally this is how to do it oh
that's easy
take off your pants all right it
encouraged mixed sex open air exercises
and hosted the first international
nudity Congress this is great this is
great this is great as a great I fully
support German nudist camps popped up
out in the woods and attracted
socialists liberals and pacifists all
who were opponents of the Nazi Party
okay interesting when Hitler came to
power he first outlawed nudism but then
brought it under regulation okay mister
it's amazing to think that like Hitler
at times was doing other things I mean
like you just think a Hitler he did one
thing but he's like maybe they should be
able to congregate node in cells and
naked zones they wonder why would you
dig out a little bit yeah you know so
restrictions were put in place because
of the Nazi belief that nudism was a
quote breeding ground for Marxists and
homosexuals and breeding and brainy yeah
mix sex nudism was out as a quote a
reaction to the increased immorality of
the Weimar State mixed sex yeah meaning
now you command it with gender nude yes
so they were saying men and women
couldn't be naked together but still it
remained very popular and even had
support among members of the SS okay
that's nice yeah that's nice an SS could
just relax a little bit Yeah right
see him with the Swazi is off it's
Germans brought their version of nudism
to America in 1929 okay they came to
America sorry when they came to America
most German immigrants went to New York
or Chicago but when they wanted to
practice nudism they ran into trouble
because going naked in a gymnasium in
Berlin was a lot different than going
naked in a gymnasium in New York yeah
well sure they got here and they just
started [__] strutting through the
Germans like weird Jesus Christ I'm just
gonna do with my legs yeah no I'm gonna
work on my leg leg day no cover up the
jimmy-jam this is a bummer dude yeah no
York I'm stuck - yeah what we live here
you know we do is shorts my buttocks
seem to have kind of copped it in a and
that's a problem action cop ask fashion
hey this is New York now yeah I can
brilliant yes
okay yes like [__] this so I get it
brilliant you look at each other's
buttholes all day but not here I don't
know I mean New York this is no but oh
so you're playing a sport no someone
snap the ball we used to play mixed you
know athletics mix athletics yeah boys
women you know messin mucking it up you
know like I'm there playing you know
whatever play volleyball play whatever
babbitt so nobody not the shuttlecocks
you've got a new name yeah where's the
shuttlecocks i know where it is actually
because one of the guys put it in
himself but that was we have like five
others so it was fine but you know that
when you say phrases like one of the
guys put it in you lose your accent
completely yeah
no that's good well I'm look it's Ted
it's me from before and you guys asked
me to leave the gym so I kind of
reinvented myself and I gave it with a
bunch of stuff so going naked in North
America at the time was about a rata
sysm burlesque
gay bath houses striptease is not about
health fitness or recreation okay the
way nudists were able to navigate this
situation was to go outside the city
nudist camps began to spring up in the
country
Kurt Barthel is considered the father of
the modern u.s. nudist movement okay he
put an ad in German papers seeking
like-minded people for a meet-up and
this in America though yeah right okay
you put out of here who wants to be
naked and just you know hang out do
naked yes like not just like regular
stuff but naked do that that's what the
ad said right okay that's you wanted
maybe take a pass no I'm get that
perfectly the first organized news
outing was held on Labor Day 1929 there
were seven people in attendance three
women in format Barthel then founded the
American League for physical culture in
1929 the members of the AAPC visited
least farms in Westchester County in the
summer and purses just participated in
gymnastics in rented gyms and pools in
the city in winter okay
he then set up America's first official
nudist camp sky farm in New Jersey and I
am armed in 1932
okay Skyfire sure to split off group
form mmm the American side the bay
sunbathing Association that is the
greatest the American sunbathing
Association
oh yeah we're pretty like just here to
have a good time make sure everyone's
like on the same page yeah and the
American gym no physical Association
weirder our names not as cool but it's
got Jim in there and then you know our
stuffs out we're also nude
we're not yeah but I don't like the way
you're nude that's why I started my own
group because when you're nude you're
like I'm gonna sunbathe and I'm like man
I want to do some sports it's cool man
it's not [__] cool you guys just lay
around dude I don't like some football
bro all right we're chill like yeah
let's play I have a disc a disc yeah
football we could play frisbee football
the [__] it matter with you this is
why we have two different groups Iranian
football feels like you want a beef did
we're on the same page [__] you man
you're a shitty nudist all right all
right yeah we're so close to fighting
right now naked fighting okay awesome
get a little exercise
no that's your guru that's you in the
goddamn face all right what do you mean
all right let's do it let's do [__] you
do what anything you want man it's cool
Renate not [__] cool man named team
man [__] you you [__] weird naked guy
all right what do you mean all right
let's go I can say that sure yeah I love
it yes indeed be [__] you don't know why
I'm horde I don't know why I'm hard
alright cool man
I'm hard too it's awesome you son of a
[__] it's cool man I agree i have black
yeah for sure I'm not crying bro fine
I'm not [__] crying man's cool it's
not your fault
it's not your fault we're still gonna
have different groups it's not your
fault
and it's not your fault dad's not your
yeah it's not your fault not your fault
okay
all right I'm just gonna put my pants on
all right
that's that's cool that's how I feel
right now ever you want to do it man
yeah here for you okay dad messed you up
man I don't wanna go all right okay I'll
see you later
All Right see you later man that is
awesome love that did in 1932 the aga is
someone right now is just like driving
their car listening to this and just
sounded like a psychopath oh god oh god
oh god in 1932 the aga established The
Rock Lodge club nudist facility New
Jersey okay
a Dutch Reformed minister started the
Christian naturist movement naturism
began expanding nationwide so the reason
nudism is catching on America was the
same as Germany it was a protest against
modern urban life with a rapid
urbanization and new consumer oriented
economy dominated by giant corporations
some Americans believed there's a
disconnection with nature and it
threatened to weaken the nation well I'm
glad to say we've solved that God make
it and they try to yeah I think there's
actually this sounds nuts but they're I
can't remember what the it's called but
it's like connectivism or something like
that where it's like people who are like
yeah we just make sure that our feet our
hands touch earth for like a half a
verse meditation and there's like
genuine like you know yeah connective
healing issues and stuff but still it's
like really you think touching the earth
is good for us it doesn't seem like that
makes any sense
also fiction like Tarzan glamorized
being naked in the forest with monkeys I
added the monkeys part that's where I
want to be by the way that's a different
kind of naked that's where you're like
well I might get these balls of mine
stuffed in my mouth okay I don't want a
monkey around
my dick out it was completely steal that
beach and two non-fiction books came out
nudism in modern life the new Jim no
fuss feed Jim no physique Jim Jim gnosis
a gymnast a fee I never heard that word
and Jan gaze on going naked Jan gays
real name was Helen reitman her father
was president of the Chicago hobo
college Ben reitman okay right yep call
back her book was about an extremely
repressed Midwestern girl who discovers
the ecstatic freedom of outdoor German
nudism these books introduced Americans
to nudism and talked [__] about
capitalism okay liberals like the erotic
possibilities of social nudity and how
it pushed change the erotic
possibilities yeah well they're still
Americans are still caught up in the
fact that if you're naked you're so so
they're well that's what they're they're
they're getting titillated by the nudism
right whereas nudists are just like
let's let's say it's not a sex thing new
this camp started popping up in rural
areas on these coasts Hobart glassy was
a Syracuse University graduate who had
worked for a while as a psychologist
okay Hobart and his wife Laura
Lu are a Laura a home economics teacher
gone into nudism okay he soon became
assistant director at upstate New York
scamp Olympia one of the first u.s.
nudist retreats he's really just great I
feel like it wasn't hard to move up in
the nudist world like there wasn't a lot
of competition as well I'm a manager or
whatever without any signature dress
code it's hard to tell who's a
lieutenant it's just a release are you
in charge here
uh yeah no I know
yeah you can charge that guy hey are you
in charge yeah no the way you're saying
it huh
no I'm not
this is one of our naked joke we're a
collective in 1933 the glasses came to
Southern California to open a nudist
camp in a more temperate climate okay a
quote eccentric iris born businessman
named Peter McConville also came with
them okay McConville had been in New
York brochure and he had been introduced
to nudism while growing up with
relatives in northern Australia that
tracks a lot of tracks no questions not
a snake yeah after three after the three
searched the area they found their spot
in the Cleveland National Forest above
Lake Elsinore that's amazing Cleveland
on the border of Orange and Riverside
counties okay 40 miles from Los Angeles
okay they leased a portion of Rhodes
ranch and built two simple cottages and
put up ten tents okay there was no
electricity or under indoor plumbing
okay so you're [__] in the woods yep
Hobart named the camp Elysian Fields see
I can do most of this no outdoor
plumbing stuff no that stuff that's when
you're done
that's camping it's new yeah but it's
nude camp like it's I mean it is like my
favorite show Nick you're not afraid
I've never said I'd be suited for it why
would I play it but it's gone camping
you [__] in the woods
I have done that yes but it's not ideal
but that's kind of a part of camping it
is yes but also being part of like a
human I think now has become like
cleaning and like you know you feel like
you feel dirty
thank you you can bring a travel bidet
that's all I'm asking for have those
they've travel bidets I'm just asking
for a friend to get a mouthful of water
and just don't do that oh don't do that
no don't oh I thought that this is what
you said no I said travel the day for
each other no yeah you bid each other
that's you're talking about two guys in
a relationship and nowadays when you're
single I think I've I think I've
conflated the - is it Elysian Fields a
lot do you know how to pronounce it I
think it would be Elise
elysian yeah I mean here they pronounce
it Elysian in Los Angeles but I'm
getting it
I'm sure it mails that it's something
else they're actually emails in May 1933
Elysian Fields had its opening weekend
yeah Elysian I think Alicia is e ly s I
am Asian
a lesion yes like what you get from a
leech they said quote their dream was to
assist people by providing a place where
the pressures of our artificial
civilization might be removed a select
list of people were invited okay
Hobart quote most of them were
professional men and women and their
families we spent the day talking and
playing various games the only
difference between our gathering and the
ordinary picnic was that we worn our
clothing yeah no no clothing yeah tough
sell for the kids probably though he no
see I disagree cuz I kids I think kids
up until a certain age just having zero
problem being I agree with that
it's the Brits the fact when you're
around adults naked as a kid it's real
weird okay like I remember the first
time I was in a locker room I like was
like what is that you know like I can't
dandle what I saw no there if you're a
kid and you see old man balls like
that's a tough that literally is why at
the YMCA they're like here's a room for
like 15 and under and then here's the
room where you're allowed to see what
happens to old guys balls it's a bummer
well guys balls is a bummer especially
the why they're weighing themselves make
you know what I mean like they have a
real culture in there ya know guys at
the Y old guys are the why I like to
just hang out naked first one you wanna
dude sitting in a chair reading a paper
oh yes sitting in a chair that other
people sit in just reading a paper some
guys doing is new tabs on the floor like
you see what my balls do when I clench
and that fun for a nine-year-old to see
are you looking at the pronunciation
yeah let's check it out I think it I
would imagine it is lesion
yeah filly an Elysian Fields so I should
have looked at it before people know
that man I'm here for the coward it's
okay someone throw a harpoon of me
excuse me
yeah that's what I've unless so went
through a harpoon at you it hit me where
all right my Tumtum
okay let's just keep going that's what
the doctor calls it
that's just my Tom Tom a lot of he rubs
you huh baby just a Hobart made a point
to assure the public that they weren't
insane quote at Meal Time we dressed in
conventional shorts okay right yeah
because you're gonna you know what I get
mustard pubes yeah it didn't take long
for word of the naked people playing
games and talking in the forest to reach
the Riverside DA's office that is what I
love is like what are they doing well
they're frolicking yeah like literally
they're breaking the chain of society
yeah there's literally the nothing else
you could give a [__] less about the
name they don't wear clothes yeah what
are they doing they're eating okay great
a few days after open District Attorney
Earl red wine and the local Sharon Wong
arrived
that's the LA Times reported quote a
belligerent district attorney yesterday
constable a red wine costate chill over
Elysian Fields and sent three promoters
of the strange cult scampering for their
trousers and overcoats weird overcoats
yeah right yeah that's where they grabs
an overcoat yeah yeah for sure
the three were all that remained of a
little group of ten who gathered Sunday
in the old Rhodes ranch to woo nature
without the benefit of clothing the only
people there were Hobart Laura and
another naked guy obviously hey my I'm
I'm single I I was I'm divorced
hello the DA was furious and lit in to
Hobart and Hobart responded quote we are
not operating a nudist colony
but a secluded vacation center where
people may go naked there is a
distinction but I mean you should not
have to defend while you're naked oh
you're making him on my property yeah
yeah
da red wine said there was no
distinction and the quote you can
commune with nature all you want as long
as you wear some clothes otherwise
there'll be no colony Riverside County
won't stand for nudism nobody in
Riverside is naked ever not once I put
on my [__] jeans before I take a
shower that's right my dungarees put
them on a shower get out of the shower I
put on giver pants and I slide the
dungarees off underneath why wouldn't
you just take off the duggar Oh cuz
you'd be nude for a second that's right
you [__] pervert sounds like I'm not
the weirdo so he wasted a lot of jeans
you're the weirdo you think man was was
like made to walk around naked in a
forum we're getting a citation or
something is there any like cuz we'll
just take it we don't need to like talk
to you for a while or anything I am
looking you in the eyes that's fine yeah
but like if there's a ticket I don't
know if one of those officers there's
take it or something here's your ticket
alright in there [__] you do you want a
hot dog yes there you go that's our hot
dog nice try
red wine made another visit a few weeks
later and always later it always does in
this household check out who's got chaps
and threatened that anyone naked would
be quote thrown in jail every day of the
week if I find anyone here without
proper clothing I like the idea that he
does start showing up with less on
though like he's like enticed by but he
does want to let him know that's right
you got to wear clothes how about I just
lose a button to calm D a red wine down
Hobart promise that every person at
Elysian Fields would wear short sweaters
or bathing suits okay sounds very legal
but he had no intention of doing that
because he knew the district attorney
no legal leg to stand on right okay
still the nudists kept a lower profile
for a while until July when Hobart sent
a letter to the LA Times columnist to a
LA Times columnist declaring the camp
fully open for business
yes Hobart quote Alicia is a half a mile
off the Ortega Highway and is reached by
a government Road which is closed to the
public by federal authorities no one
accepting those having business with the
inhabitants of the area may travel this
road without being subject to fine or
imprisonment or both okay so to get
there you have to private try to get
there so no one should be arrested
because it's completely no one's gonna
stumble across no kid or whatever you're
[__] worried about is gonna stumble
across the nudists right right
the glasses then went on a PR tour
trying to build up good relationships
with their neighbors and they donated to
local charities and took part in
community events after a while of doing
this Hobart was convinced Alicia was
safe even da red wine back down the LA
calmest took note and was impressed
quote he is clever when he started the
Elysian Fields there was a roar of
protest from citizens officials but that
is all quieted down now okay that's it
good into the story congratulations nice
pretty good yeah there's a little bit
more people were still fascinated with
the nudist camp though and Hollywood
came calling
what a former child actor named Brian
Foy I want to get in direct to directing
and producing and he saw Alicia as the
perfect opportunity and I'm interested
to see where this man's vision goes
voyons crew began filming a fictional
quote health film okay it was about a
reporter who comes to find a nudist
colony as a skeptic and leaves converted
uh-huh right okay I happens I like that
yeah I see Dudley Moore quote we decided
we just put everybody on the screen
naked maybe then we'd do some business
okay so alright so your movies probably
not great plot wise your plan now is to
just show a bunch of genitals right okay
and it a fully-clothed the Hobart gives
a lecture in front of a campfire about
the benefits of nudism okay
great saying I did that I did that
speech in my zone TV audition
otherwise yeah and then I have use it
for additions like winch it winch it I
did it might be a little long for what
you're looking for and please know
you'll see why this works with a winch
adjusts a winch into the camera no no no
no I got an actual thing prepared I'm
gonna take off my shirt okay
in November 1933 Elisha Valley of the
nudes premiered at Tally's criterion
theatre in Los Angeles
the LA Times film critic did not enjoy
it now interesting quote attempting in
all seriousness attempting in all
seriousness to set forth the theories of
a the nudist cult but often
unconsciously comical Elisha seem to be
drawing audiences largely of men
yesterday yeah that really is what it's
gonna turn into right here we go watch
this film down at the theater it's about
you know people getting into a thing
that they're in dude I'm gonna go whack
off at the movies on see us sir I'm here
to find out about that nature the nature
help situation in Iran naked my question
is do I gotta buy one firm I took it
from my friend here this little guy the
hog sir no huh could you leave actually
be great if you would leave don't look
at me I'm gonna go in how much it cost
for have a popcorn that ain't got the
bottom okay sir for whacking them it's
four dollars alright hey you know that's
from my bottom what that's where my
money was later
[Applause]
so I'll go back to this what excuse of
entertainment it aims to offer is
difficult to conjecture outside of
arousing a period curiosity on the part
of some beholder the viewer also said
there was a lot of lecture yeah you know
what I want to see is a movie of just
naked people actually again I mean they
were covering plot issues with nudes
it's not a great so yeah it's like it's
all speeches yeah hey so why are you
naked well it's a long long long long
monologue and here I go the lectures
were full of pseudo-scientific claims
like exposing the naked body to the Sun
was necessary to recuperate and build up
the flesh mm-hmm
quote the American Indian never caught
colds until the white man put clothes on
him well that's that's not an issue we
can argue with and there were the soon
standard shots of nudists playing
football baseball sunbathing and eating
in the nude as well as the racist talk
of saying staying fit enough to quote
outdo the savage at any sort of game
wait what
racist you know ray start out do the
savage and A's are a game yeah the
savage you know who said that though
they said that are in the film oh okay
that's one of the benefits right okay of
nudism right interesting twist yeah
probably
there's nothing like nudism and white
supremacy thrown in together yeah no
you're probably watching that like just
do that that's right and we're all one
unless you're not white all right let's
move over here come on what'd he say he
said white dicks white dicks they're the
right ones let's go the powers that be
in America were not thrilled with the
movie it was banned in Los Angeles
another American city cities it was
banned in all of Puerto Rico where the
President issued a statement nobly quote
if nude men and women appeared in the
streets of San Jose the police would
have to restrain them okay
okay all right I guess I'm taking off my
clothes all right not clear no officer
don't know not clear what I was saying
tackle me don't tackle him not [__] with
all this blow bar blow back Hobart
decided to move Elisha to a more
strategic location sure in 1934 Hina's
investors bought a secluded piece of
land further up the Ortega Highway and
moved the camp there the land was
located in both Riverside and Orange
counties ok so it straddles right a
reporter asked Hobart about this quote
it was purchased with full of knowledge
of the fact it was partly in Orange
County and partly in Riverside County as
a matter of fact the thought that such
an arrangement might be of value in
receiving district attorneys and sheriff
squads was one of the reasons why the
land was purchased
if relations become strained and I
sincerely hope they did not we would
play hide and seek with the unwelcome
visitors oh ok well the Riverside
officers were seeking on their side of
the line we would be hiding on the
Orange County side and vice versa that
is smart for a second sounded like it
sounds flawed but that doesn't yeah
unless both sides come at once yes then
that's yeah they also read across a
story in the newspaper out near Ontario
there was a forest fire and the firemen
were going in and always naked people
around it was brought it was break
clothes Hobart then invited the
California governor to elesia okay
bold move yeah one of those things the
governor probably won't do it was like
well I don't all do it yeah I'll take
this time off governor and his jacket
and the shirt no now's the time I gotta
let you know about my spare nipples
there's a few mainly back an alarming
amount of people have a third nipple
yeah but the governor was afraid he
would have to get naked if he went
Hobart told the reporter they would
consider altering the rules quo
we possibly would allow him to wear at
least a pair of shorts you can cup it
we've agreed that you make up your stuff
and plug your pothole you may do that
may I have the governor's butt plug it
is but they built up the Nou Camp a mess
hall recreation hall sleeping quarters
and the commissary okay and they started
a nudist newspaper okay the nudes paper
the nudes the camp was taking off it was
incorporated as fraternity elesia okay
and soon had 200 members solid yeah they
would take applications to get in
someone would do a home visit and an
interview uh-huh because they didn't
want creeps I'm and clearly a lot of
creeps would read it for sure
out of 6,000 applications only 200 and
Wow during the summer around 75 people
could be found daily at the camp but
that number plummeted to half a dozen in
the winter hobart quote in the winter
there isn't so much disrobing yeah only
first names were used at the camp
interesting a reporter for the Santa
Cruz Sentinel was told only wholesome
and decent persons were allowed to join
okay quote no snickering fools are
tolerated and we are not a cult or a
similar organization we do not eat herbs
or roots we live just like other people
the nudists are very sanitary routes
there's a lot judgment who's getting
root shape all right look I don't eat
root so I'm not dirty oh you thought
about that dirty root eater god dammit
that [__] Rudy you ruined all of our
[__] dude I didn't eat the roads well
then what the [__] you digging him up
for I was gonna make a soup but I'm not
anymore
what are you naked guys it's better have
a monkey you don't understand what's
being spring came in 1934 they met their
biggest enemy yet clothes swarming bees
oh [__] yeah thousands of them Oh God
the LA Times dr. glossy opined that bees
are no
in any settlement but in a nudist colony
the service of attack is many times
increased the defender get is greatly
handicapped by aerial assaults from all
directions at one time yeah that's also
I mean it getting stunk sucks but if you
get stung ooh you know they're not good
yeah he also said the bees were creating
a mental issue that was quote seriously
cramping the carefree life and out of
door goes that form an important part of
the colony's routine right so now
everyone's like angry yeah damn it you
can't have you can't have fun a bad man
when there's bees around no stinging
penises first time Bart called a local
judge but he said bees weren't in his
jurisdiction look find him guilty and
get them off the land please Your Honor
can we get a warrant something look I
don't know how the law works but can we
put them in a bee jail I don't I don't
think there's any precedent for me
giving a bee warrant these bees are
criminals all right
here is a warrant for the bees to leave
your property now if they don't respect
this what's our next move like if they
air bees I I would I think we might have
to do the unthinkable heard of a fogger
hmm you could bring in a new queen
that's interesting yeah one of us will
dress like the coining yes
boom thank you your honor so I'm the
queen you're all my subjects let's go
this way for a while so he the judge
referred him to the local agricultural
inspector he said that guy said there's
not a lot that can be done yeah they're
bees they're just kind of doing what
they do he did tell them that killing
bees was in self-defense was legal hmm
and then he referred them to a local bee
inspector it turns out it was a guy
starting a bee farm next door and they
handled it okay the bee inspectors like
when I got to the bottom of it's right
there yeah there's a guy with a bunch of
ah bad October there was a fire after a
suspicious explosion in the commissary
okay
locals rushed up to help and it was the
clothed and unclothed working together
for the greater good probably a little
weird for half you know it's awkward oh
yeah
if you could just move your penis I can
help get that out of there I can't okay
I'll just touch it but why are you
trying to you know I'm [__] with my life
there's a fire Oh is there a fire yeah
you just mad cuz my dicks out I'm well
I'm not crazy about it but there's a
fire so it was just take these these
your hats you [__] with my lifestyle bro
there's a fire yeah a [__] fire yeah
but I'm also naked and that's your it's
your own [__] hang up no I'm like
whatever about that I really I'm just
trying to help you guys there's been an
explosion there's a fire alright cool
man thanks for coming up here at the man
okay I mean yeah sorry I'm just again
I'm trying to just get some stuff
alright man good to meet you I'm just
gonna help wasn't yeah alright alright
see you later buddy hey this guy hates
naked people that's not fair he's on the
ranch man doesn't seem like anyone
really has your bag he doesn't see my
fire I guess it was pretty freaked out
[Music]
the newly-built kitchen the mess hall
and the recreation hall were all lost
Oh Bart said a prowler had been seen the
week before after this
Alisha started falling apart and
infighting began by early 1935 there was
a deep rift among the nudists over how
to run the camp some backed Hobart and
others backed Pete McConville the
colony's business manager
word of the warring factions got to the
press makandal was asked about it and
told the LA Times quote either glassy or
I must go
well it seems like we've lost the plot a
little bit in the forest but the glasses
were spending less and less time in
Allegiant anyway and more in Los Angeles
Hobart said he was still in charge and
that McConville was doing a bad job as
the financial manager Hobart said he was
willing to buy or sell he didn't care no
one outside the group ever knew what the
fight was over McConville said he would
turn the land into a chicken farm okay
reported that but I think he was [__]
around okay the conv won the batterer
battle either bought or forced Hobart
out and McConville took over the camp
while Hobart kept control of the
corporation named fraternity elesia
okay so the glassy set up a new nudist
camp at La Tuna Canyon in Sun Valley
okay no it was much closer to Los
Angeles in Orange County it's also about
ten minutes from here right yeah it was
known as the ranch okay McConville
changed the name from Elisha to Olympian
Fields okay he's like a whole Greek yeah
it's not surprised you just want to put
your stink on the business a little bit
your stinking wrong turn with the
attention-seeking Hobart gone the old
now smaller nudist colony flew under the
radar okay Hobart continued pushing
nudism giving frequent talks at the
Clifton cafeteria in Los Angeles
okay I know you're all eating but I'd
like to talk about having a dick out um
great Jesus try the cheesecake don't
touch our food this is a [__] and balls
okay this this is no different than
being around a redwood sorry here's you
calamari majors yes put him on here nope
okay he wrote several articles that were
published in the nudist magazine sure
the new nudist colony thrived Charles
Richter along with Ben Oh Gutenberg came
up with the Richter scale to measure
earthquakes in 1935 okay that same year
he and his wife became regulars at the
glass EES new nudist camp that's just it
now Dave if you've done nothing else in
your life it's that you've changed
forever the way I'll imagine the
Richter's
yeah and it measures that anyway Helen
and I are going after the woods
we don't wear clothes anymore see ya at
caltech many of his fellow workers
viewed Richter with unease for his part
he just saw nudism as a way to become
closer to humanity
he wrote that his wife Lillian was a
much better nudist than he was yes she
oh my god doesn't wear anything either
oh [__] great a picnic is really
naked when I take my clothes off oh my
god I'm not very good at this but when
she's making it huh holy [__] you're
like that's great
you're the best yeah and then you're
like why did you marry that nude guy and
then nobody says anything this is like a
nightmare scenario I see in my leg I'm
painting my own anyway
am i talking out loud I shouldn't be no
one's here oh that's perfect I said that
to myself and I'm talking to a tree I
don't have a wife yay earthquake
[Music]
so she quote rejoices in fresh air son
and healthy exercise okay
Richter said he never knew what real
friendship was until quote we joined the
glassy group that's so he never really
felt at home and tell he was naked and
Jimmy Canyon doesn't hang with his
buddies yep the glasses had their second
none sorry another miracle oh god damn
it it's a nun again these are the worst
to raise the glasses had their second
son it was the first baby born in the
new year in Los Angeles in 1937 okay
five seconds after he was named Gareth
what the what no what he was yeah really
Gareth classy yeah just take a minute I
went uh Gradius shut up a read your
stupid story meanwhile in 1938
McConville allowed another health film
to be shot at Alisha and the first one
was a health film yeah oh yeah they're
right health films right okay you
was called unashamed a romance oh no no
I don't like any of this it's a porno
this is gonna be a porno he's gonna
accidentally make porn in it McConville
played a game keeper this is the IMD
description ray Lane entices her
workaholic boss to come to a nudist camp
in the hopes of winning his heart things
go swimmingly until attractive and pert
blonde Barbara captures his attention
this is a port that sounds like a pawn
it's port III I couldn't figure out but
it sounds yeah it's not it doesn't sound
a health at all it sounds I want to [__]
yeah and there's naked people it's just
basic and there's two yes yeah yep they
were splits in the news community that
were highlighted at a convention in
Santa Cruz in 1937 okay the leader in
Santa Cruz called his group the Elysium
foundation hmm similar you get very
similar and held this convention two
weeks before Hobart and fraternity
elesia were going to hold their
convention in San Diego total [__]
prick 390 delegates came a
representative from Hobart's group went
up and talked [__] to the press saying
it was unethical miss named and
unauthorized okay no naked people
authorized this it's just it's like the
you're just are already going like oh no
even this is becoming like a corporation
you can you can walk around naked in the
force that's someone else trying to walk
yeah we're taking your company name I'm
making the forest intellectual property
like you seriously you can't even do
this yeah and it's so and this there's
no hundred percent against what it's
supposed to be about right yeah and this
movement has started because of like
yeah let's you know get along and yeah
it's not worried about totally don't
commune with nature man really how about
I commune with nature
whatever muting with nature better what
doing it a week before you I hope a bee
stings your wife's breasts well that's
how we get off it's true it's a fetish
that point zero zero one percent of the
population is into and it's really hard
it's the worst
because you have to get a B that will do
it and that's complicated you know what
we call it boobies
I'll see you all later and she walked
into a river
so Hobart's representative also said
there was a lack of quote orthodox
nudism in as much as a few pair of
panties and a sprinkling of brassieres
were in evidence and i'm not very happy
about that this is a nudism is panties
in there I'm looking in your direction
panty where's seven of the colonies
didn't even exist so seven I call he's
ever registered he says are real seven
of these colonies don't even exist
is that real nudist colonies these
people of [__] clothes on this is
just Fresno quote he indicated that a
pants wearing nudists was no nudists at
all and a pantsless knew disassociating
with such should be shaken from the
orthodox ranks this man hates pants
she's really got a fancy she really
against pants panties pants preservers
the leader of the convention said he was
this is all clearly jealousy from Hobart
both conventions though were
successfully held things took a turn for
the worse what
that's what matters that's right things
took a turn for the worst of the ranch
on March 27 1939 Hobart was working on a
trestle that had been used for handling
or in an old silver mine on the letona
Canyon property one of the pieces of
wood gave way and he filled 25 feet and
died instantly oh [__] Hobart was 36
Richter called that quote a great blow
to the whole organization but Laura kept
the ranch going a year later the 19 year
old daughter of a famous silent film
actress shot herself with a 22 rifle at
the ranch she had disappeared for four
hours in the middle of the night and her
36 year old husband accused her of being
naughty with another male nudists so he
called the guy on the phone and they
were yelling at each other and then
while they were yelling at each other
she shot herself oh [__] the press one
nuts yeah nudism was called quote a
corruption of the mine oh for god's and
i called of course they're gonna blame
nudism
of course they are instead of just like
two people [__] around on their
husband like yeah it's like it's it's a
tale as all this time and they're like
when you lose your clothes you lose your
mind no the [__] shootings because
video games that's why there's so many
shootings in sweden the Los Angeles
Herald Express ran an expose on nudism a
week later okay
the sheriff said he was going to conduct
a nudist survey to find out what all
these nudists were doing and how many
camps there were yeah let's see what
they're doing up I miss my boys out to
find naked people we're gonna see what
these naked people are up to and we were
gonna use the bloodhounds but they need
an article of clothing to sniff to find
the perpetrators and in this situation
that tactic has been rendered useless
now Bobby said the butthole were
nevermind it's a long story we're
talking about it for about two days it
was really graphic and horrifying to be
honest LA Times quote the sheriff
pointed out that while there is no law
prohibiting the establishment of the
camp's there is also no law against
finding out what they're all about okay
sure I guess what's what is law yeah I
can investigate wherever the [__] I want
whether it's legal or not all right that
does it
right now I'm an investigator's doughnut
okie dokie guilty what the hell is
happening full meltdown full meltdown a
series of raids were conducted on the
ranch laura was arrested numerous times
the charges were a stretch including
quote allowing men and women to mingle
while nude yes we've all heard that law
good yeah do not break felony yeah use
me don't mingle while nude the ranch was
secluded the cops would watch with
binoculars from a distance there from
the distance yeah I'm single and ready
to mmm meet up really watches they even
made a two-minute film using a telephoto
lens from the surrounding hillsides to
show in court oh wow
it showed men women and children
sunbathing and swimming nude around the
oh my god end this all the charges they
brought against Laura never led to
anything more than fines and probation
and then world war two came which made
nudism seem like not that big of a deal
right but then the war ended and the
LAPD turned their sights back on naked
people minding their own business an
anti nudity law was passed which stated
three or more nude persons not of the
same sex wooden could not be in a
facility together okay so so three three
and three nude dudes could hang out
three women women hanging out but two
dudes and a woman cannot hey not right
so in 1946 a male and female officer
posed as nudists and applied for a
membership it's funny going undercover
where are we gonna put the wires Sarge
we talked about the butt hole right
that's oh I thought I was just doing a
bit really
ya know up your butthole okay awesome
it's the 50s so this is huge yeah that's
enormous it looks like a can yeah it is
a can yes okay and then there's a string
attached to it oh and that goes to the
other cave that's right don't you think
they're gonna notice the string I doubt
it all right
off we go think I'll be lookin in the
front end okay but I can't talk through
yeah I will figure it out oh my god my
my worry is that it just sounds like
cavernous nothingness but we'll see can
you hear me how hey pass the macaroni
salad I said hey Jim sure but but
talking oh yeah yeah my dad had one too
how's it going in there
oh I need to go to the hills to talk to
a non officer idiots
so they so this mail and film officer go
apply for membership they signed form
saying they accepted nudism and that it
was beneficial for their health they
took a tour of the camp where they saw
quote a score of persons including two
young girls and four boys playing
badminton ping-pong and sunbathing nude
at the camp hmm two more cops than
showed up and someone yelled the coppers
are here and everyone put their clothes
on okay Laura and her new partner were
arrested they went to trial and were
found guilty Laura got a hundred and
eighty days in prison
the ACLU got involved and the case was
appealed all the way to the Supreme
Court who ruled the nudists personal
liberties were not being unduly
restricted Wow our Supreme Court is
[__] [__] well right now it's
about but it's it's yeah slavery was
cold there it's a [__] garbage yes
yes the decision stood Laura and her new
partner went to jail the ranch closed
richter called the episode quote about
as nasty a little story of the failure
of a minority group to secure its secure
its constitutional rights as I know of
clearly he had never heard of slavery or
other service take a moment this process
I think about this one take four five
literally five seconds before you say
what you're about to say he continued to
be a nudist for years but nothing ever
compared to the ranch for him Laura went
on to marry the guy who had been her new
business partner McConville aged and
eventually sold that his nudist camp in
1954 to a couple named Wally and Flo
Nielsen McCombie lived there until he
died in 1959 well they were still using
his scrotum as a tent
after the Nelsons renamed the camp
McConville in his honor also and I said
he had Ville in his name yeah yeah yeah
they you they raised their children in
the nude there they added resort style
improvements there was a bathhouse a
swimming pool and tennis courts but the
Nielsen's divorced in the cemani zinf'
Loeb became the sole owner of the
hundred and twenty nine acre camp
it had a small membership and locals
liked them they even would Bowl nude at
the local bowling alley every week
though it was closed to the public and
windows were covered but they still got
naked bowling time yeah I mean it's like
when especially if you show up on black
night you're like this isn't like black
light night you know what I mean like I
was like anything cool you can see how
the colors on your shirt you're like no
it's just where's naked by then nudism
you wear shoes do you wear bowling yeah
they were for sure they don't wear
brothers you can't bowling in bare feet
good god man imagine that look by then
nudism being some statement about life
was gone so so much had changed over the
years that nudism didn't I mean now
we've got you know Playboy in penthouse
by that time it's like nudism isn't like
scandalous or like wow you know right
and the camp still did not have
electricity which caused membership to
decline more in 1991 a reporter from the
LA Times visited an X TV stage manager
now helped run the camp he was just in a
western scarf and cowboy boots yeah I
love it love it we finally have it here
perfect you meant boots don't make me
shoot you quote it feels so damn good
not to have to put something on when you
get up in the morning you're dressed he
lived at the camp for 11 years with his
wife and two daughters
he said camp officials were leery of
single men half a dozen kids were living
at the camp year-round at that point
a reporter watched them riding around on
bikes nude and mm flow renamed it can't
miss the goats and oaks and changed it
to nude optional
but new members didn't come and in 2007
mr. cokes closed and with it the dreams
of the you and I of the naked to naked
dream well yeah
it's it's very it you always it is weird
when you think about clothes when you
think about like how it is you have to I
mean especially when you grow up in it
you're like you have to wear clothes you
just have to wear clothes but yeah this
is really weird it is really really like
we shouldn't I mean you should write you
should I mean protective clothing sure
but for the most part you should be able
to just be like yeah yeah why not
but it's weird that it's illegal yeah
but then it's something that's not in a
lot of places it isn't illegal like
right but but but mostly I mean
certainly you know I've read a ton of
stories and twenties thirties and stuff
where they just made it super illegal
and bathing suits really all kinds of
[__] see and it depends where to like
you need to have the right like you
couldn't right now we could not say
you'd like clothing optional in Los
Angeles so it'd be a terrible
I bet I wonder if you can walk around
like a woman walk around there time well
in New York there yeah yeah there's
certain parks were you you are allowed
to walk run yeah so there's and that's
why it should be I mean the the whole
stigmatizing nudity is [__] insane
yeah it really is it's like the folk
yeah the focus the things we choose to
focus on are it's all because of the
religious [__] where people can't they
can't handle their dicks they can't
imagine seeing flesh in human form and
not wanting to either what you fart if
you [__] that yeah yeah exactly yeah no
what if you just hang out and say that's
a beautiful body now you [__] it yeah I
mean really that is what religion is
it's like it's like pence saying he
can't go and be alone with a woman or
like something like that cuz why did
that you can't I know you're super weird
you know what I've always loved about
that one too is the idea that any woman
would want to be alone with Mike Pence
like yeah Mike Mike don't worry the
society set that condition for you too
Wow yeah nudism trip I always want
everything in uzum I was think of mash
which I walk watching as a kid and
Hawkeye was always reading nudist
magazines always people it was only just
Maggie this Maggie so it was always it
was so that was during the Korean War
which is the fifties it was it was
before Playboy stuff so they had news
magazines and it was people playing
sports nude and he always was looking at
well he would not be allowed there for
the wrong reasons all right that was
scandalous yeah very interesting
more people should be nude that's my
opinion especially you let's get this
done let's let's shut these mics off all
right keep the camera going oh thank you